hello and welcome to kaiogen's webinar
on optimized sample processing and
digital pcr-based workflow for
wastewater monitoring of cyrus cov2 my
name is dominic o'neill i'm the director
for microbiome product development at
kyogen i will be discussing the sample
processing and my colleague colin
donahoe will talk about the digital
pcr-based workflow
before we start a quick legal disclaimer
any products that we speak about here
today are intended for molecular biology
applications and not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of
disease
so on our agenda for today is an
introduction on the importance of
wastewater surveillance for stars cov2
and then we'll go into the wastewater
testing workflow that we have been
developing at kyogen
starting with the importance of
inhibitor removal technology discussing
some of the concentration methods that
we've looked at
and ending with the full sample
preparation workflow then colin will
provide some digital pcr background
as well as data on digital pcr
quantification of sars cov2 in
wastewater and at the end we have time
for questions
so there's been tremendous interest in
wastewater testing for sarsko to
surveillance over the past year and it's
because the benefits of this technology
are potentially immense
cost has been estimated that it could
save up to about a billion dollars in
monitoring programs by testing on a
population basis rather than individuals
the sensitivity can be huge you can find
infected individuals in populations of
100 to up to 2 million people to
potentially find outbreaks before they
spread
and you can increase your coverage
dramatically by looking at
billions of people potentially
monitoring through their sewage
treatment plants rather than trying to
do individual testing
so detection of viruses in wastewater
has been known for quite some time in
particular for poliovirus for example
and those
techniques are adaptable very easily to
sars cov2 detection it's known that sars
cov2 passes through the intestinal tract
in a shed into the wastewater and
therefore testing waste water
with the associated fecal matter will
pick up sars cov2 viral rna if it's
present from infected individuals in the
catchment and so for that the wastewater
treatment plant is going to be the
natural place to do this testing as it
will gather in
sample from the entire catchment area
giving you a broad cross-section of the
population
and then looking directly at the
influence sample coming in before it
goes to any treatment that could
potentially decrease the signal
aside from potentially looking at the
sludge that comes settled out
is going to probably provide the best
sensitivity
and the sample needs to be taken
processed in some way because it's
normally quite dilute so it needs to be
concentrated the nucleic acids need to
be extracted through different methods
and that's shown here on the right
different concentration methods with
whether you're working with
the
raw influence or whether you're working
with settled sludge
and then for detection there's a variety
of methods but for scope v2 pcr-based
methods and digital pcr-based methods
are going to be the most common method
used
and as mentioned in this slide
earlier
the importance of sars kovi to
wastewater-based epidemiology
is to detect small amounts of sars-cov2
in complex samples
perform surveillance for public health
decisions
which will let you understand the extent
of the community spread
provide early detection which you can
then potentially use to prevent
community outbreaks
predict new infections and quarantine
people as the outbreaks begin
and also very interestingly is
potentially used to monitor variant
spread the variance should also be
detectable in the wastewater and with
sequencing or digital pcr multiplexing
mode various variants can be detected
so for each step along the workflow for
cyrus cov2 wastewater-based epidemiology
kaiogen has solutions for collecting
dealing with collected samples for
disrupting the samples for extracting
the samples for doing detection and for
doing data analysis for example using
any of our manual kits or the automation
options here for doing the main primary
sample extraction followed by the qod
digital pcr instrument and the kaikyod
software seat for doing the data
analysis provides a complete workflow
now i will talk in detail about the
sample preparation portion of the
workflow so about collecting samples
about sample disruption and sample
extraction
so before i go into the data that i have
to show um just here a quick excerpt
from a paper from september of 2020 from
dr juarez ahmed
on surveillance of sarsko v2 rna in
wastewater talking about the methods of
optimization
and here their conclusion is also that
rna extraction kits that are streamlined
and that are equipped with pcr inhibitor
removal technologies are going to be the
most useful um to reduce the chance of
contamination waste water
are dirty they have a huge amount of
inhibitors present and are very very
difficult to get clean rna and dna out
particularly when you don't know what
the status of the viral rna is and how
degraded it might be
and so that of course is uh very
important the inhibitors that are being
talked about here
are inhibitors are small chemicals that
are released at the same time that you
break open cells or when you disrupt
your biological sample
these could be for example humic fulvic
acids coming from soil polysaccharides
polyphenolics and plants bile bilirubin
heme and stool for example as well as
others
and these are potent inhibitors of
downstream pcr assays
on the right you can see a
pcr curve um of a same sample
processed with and without hydrogen's
inhibitor removal technology
and without
the inhibitor removal technologies those
are the curves labeled as plus
inhibitors you can see a dramatic shift
in ct to the right where the samples are
coming up much later
and this is due to these inhibitor
samples and this clearly is going to
decrease your sensitivity when doing a
pcr you won't detect positive samples if
you do not remove your inhibitors ahead
of time
um and so we looked at this we looked to
see how critical it is for
wastewater samples to use irt so irt is
kyogen's proprietary inhibitor removal
technology it is present in any kit that
has power in its name so the all-prep
power viral the rna-z power water the r
and e-z power microbiome for example
those all contain this irt
now the chi amp viral rna mini kit is
standardly used for stars cov2
detection of extraction and analysis in
swab samples for example but it's not
designed to deal with fecal material or
sewage samples and here when we compare
it we see that as well using
um
different concentration methods whether
we spun down and processed a pellet or
did ultra
filtration or did electronegative
filtration on a mix cellulose ester
membrane
we see a significant background shift in
cts when we prep those materials with
the ky amp viral rna mini kit and we see
much better consistent detection using
either the all prep power viral or the
rnez power water kit and this is an
indication that there are potent
inhibitors present in the sample that
are removed through the use of irt
so we strongly recommend any irt kit
when dealing with wastewater samples
so i mentioned on the earlier slide that
any irt kit will be recommended so
that's true for any of the r and easy
irt kits and we recommend multiple kits
here because they use a very consistent
chemistry so the rnez power microbiome
the rnez power water and the all prep
power viral dna rna are all suitable for
viral detection and wastewater we have
tested all of them on actual wastewater
samples successfully
and the reason that they are
interchangeable as you can see in this
chart here they use similar lysis
buffers similar irt similar binding and
washing the differences are in the bead
beading which we have found not to be
necessary for stars cov2 detection the
virus is the viral rna
is not
protected in a way that requires bead
beading to to recover it
and dna's treatment since you're doing a
specific rt pcr at the end is generally
also not required the dna in this case
will not interfere and so we would
generally leave that out
and in that case these kits are
basically the same and can be used
interchangeably
with one caveat that i'll talk about
later
so
looking at the virus concentration
methods i talked in the previous slide
that we had looked at pellets we had
looked at mixed cellulose ester
membranes and we also looked at
ultrafiltration those are all methods
that are described here and as standard
methods of doing concentration of sars
cov2 in wastewater we were interested to
see whether there was one method that we
could recommend over any other
so here you can see that we attempted to
extract sars cov2 from samples
concentrated over mixed cellulose
membranes
ultra filtration repentance or through
spinning down and processing the pellets
and we get similar detection from this
wastewater sample in any three of the
methods so any concentration method is
theoretically compatible with our irt
kits and can be recommended
however not all wastewater samples are
equally amenable to all concentration
methods so what we also found here
looking at different wastewater
treatment plants
is that different materials are going to
be differently suited to the
concentration method so in this
experiment we looked at two different
wastewater treatment plants one of the
plants was more of a municipal plant it
was collecting sewage that was flowing
through the sewage system had more
solids had more human material present
it created a very strong pellet
and so when we spun it down we could
have got a lot of material that we could
process as a pellet directly into our
kit when we tried to process the
material through the ultrafiltration
membranes or through the mccellulose
esters those methods clogged
and were not able to process more than
10 15 mls
compared to extracting out of 50 mls
when we were doing the pellet system and
as you can see we got much better
detection for that municipal plant when
dealing with the pellet
the other plant that we were dealing
with was a more general plant it
included water flowing over overland
streams had more environmental runoff
and that provided better results with
the filtered material slightly it had
signal in the pellet as well
much more comfortable between all three
methods and was also easily filterable
through all of the methods
so the particular sample used um will
affect
which concentration method is going to
work best in your laboratory um the
important note is that all of our kits
will work well for all concentration
methods
so our recommendations for
doing
rna extraction from wastewater
is to filter your sample
if you filter your sample you should use
the rna z power water kit because that
provides five mil tubes to do processing
of the larger filter if you're going to
concentrate the sample through pelleting
or through ultra filtration then the all
prep power viral dna rna or the rnez
power microbiome kit work well
in our experience of testing different
waste water samples bead beading is not
necessary also not harmful this may vary
depending on your particular sample and
particularly when doing filters bead
beading may help to scrape material off
of those filters
and so we don't
not recommend we don't recommend that
people do not do bead beading but we do
not find that it's necessary likewise
dna's digestion is not necessary when
using these kits
there is a standard protocol for the
iron easy power microbiome kit
and a custom protocol for the all-prep
power viral kit on the kaia cube the
custom protocol can be requested through
our apps lab
and we are working on standardizing and
releasing the all prep power viral also
as a standard
kayak cube process
and that brings me to the end of my
slides and here i'd like to just leave
off with another excerpt from a paper by
dr ahmed
um
concluding that extraction of
lysate using the rnez power microbiome
and kai keep connect platform to obtain
a high quality rna
is highly suitable for wastewater
analysis thank you for your attention
and
i'll hand it over to colin for the
additional pcr portion thank you
thanks dominic now i'm going to tell you
guys how you can use the kai acuity
digital pcr system to detect sars kovi 2
in your wastewater samples
i'd just like to reiterate a few things
that dominic has already said about sars
cov2 and wastewater testing before going
any further
the real advantage of using wastewater
samples to monitor sars kobe 2 is that
within a single sample of wastewater
hundreds thousands and even millions of
people are represented and this allows
researchers to get a much better
snapshot of the community spread of sars
kobe 2 when compared to looking at
individual clinical samples and this
data from wastewater can be used as an
early warning sign for outbreaks and
allows researchers to get a snapshot of
sars cov2varian spread within a single
sample
and they can relate the quantities of
each variant to each other very easily
now digital pcr is particularly well
suited to this
task because unlike qpcr digital pcr is
absolute quantification where no
standard curve is required allowing data
collected from between various sites to
be compared with great certainty and
precision owing to the fact that the
data is absolute in its quantification
additionally because digital pcr
quantitates a little bit differently
from qpcr
the chemistry is a little bit more
robust to
the wastewater samples which are known
to contain
pcr inhibitors
so why is the kai acuity nanoplate
digital pcr system ideal for wastewater
testing
first of all the time to result with the
nanoplate is only two hours which is
much shorter than the five hours it
takes using the conventional digital
droplet pcr system from bio-rad
second
the kai acuity nano plate system is
capable of high multiplexing up to five
plex
meaning that users can detect multiple
sars cov2 variants within a single
reaction well
lastly the kai acuity nanoplate system
is fully integrated
in its workflow and offers users the
flexibility
of throughput and resolution
the plates
are very similar
to qpcr plates in their shape and well
layout and the 24 and 96 well plate
options allow users
the flexibility of throughput and
resolution all at once
i'd like to take a brief moment to point
out the features of the kai acuity
nanoplates and how they differ from the
digital droplet pcr workflow
in the kayaking nanoplate you can see
your results literally in the raw image
of each and every well on your nanoplate
second of all
sealed nanoplates prevent contamination
between wells once your reaction mixes
in a l it's in a closed environment and
it stays there
solid partitions compared to the
droplets have a very reproducible size
and therefore are particularly well
suited for the poisson calculations
that underlie digital pcr which rely on
a distinct and discrete partition volume
because we can image an entire well at
once and not via the flow cytometry
style of digital droplet pcr the readout
is fast
and because our plates are the
standardized format of all
pcr plates
the workflow is very simple and anyone
who's familiar with qpcr will have no
problem jumping in to the kayaking
nanoplate world
of course in order to use the kai acuity
nanoplates you need kai acuity
instruments and here i'd like to talk
about the four instruments that we have
available
we have a single plate instrument called
the kai acuity one which comes in two
configurations there's the two channel
instrument or the five channel
instrument
next to that we have two higher
throughput instruments called the kaia
q84 and the kaia q8 which can process
four or eight plates respectively in
parallel
and both of those instruments come only
in one configuration with respect to
multiplexing and that's the five channel
system
on this slide we have the consumables
from kyogen which you can use to detect
sars kovi 2 and wastewater as mentioned
before cayegian offers nanoplates in a
variety of formats
26k nanoplates contain 26 000 partitions
per well allowing users to load up to 28
microliters of sample per 40 microliter
reaction
alternatively users can opt for the
lower resolution 8.5 k nano plate which
comes in two formats 24 well and 96 well
or 8 500 partitions per well
are found with reaction volumes of 12
microliters where users can use up to
seven microliters of sample per reaction
we have a kai acuity one-step viral
rt-pcr kit developed special for cyrus
cov2 detection it comes in one size
enough for 520 reactions in 26k
nanoplates
and the kit contains the 4x master mix
100x multiplex reverse transcription mix
and rnas free water it's not available
on web shop ordering but if you're
interested contact your kayak and sales
specialists to order
it for the one step viral rt pcr kit we
came up with distinct single and
multi-plate workflows
for users interested in only processing
a single plate at a time
we came up with a single plate workflow
which works on all kai acuity
instruments
as is part of all kai acuity workflows
users assemble their reaction mixes in
so-called pre-plates
and after they've set up their reactions
in pre-plates they transfer the reaction
mix to a nanoplate seal the nanoplate
and then put the nanoplate into the kai
acuity instrument
where there rt incubation and two-step
kai acuity pcr cycling take place
without any additional user input
now
for users interested in processing
multiple plates in parallel using the
kai acuity 4 and 8 instruments we came
up with a dedicated multi-plate workflow
owing to the fact that reverse
transcriptases are not meant to be
sitting around for the length of time
that it would require if one were to
load a full
8 plate or 4 plate instrument and wait
up to hours until the reverse
transcription step in the cycling
program took place this is particularly
important for the generation of
non-specific signal or spurious
side products which you don't want
happening at room temperature therefore
we came up with the idea that users
would assemble
their reaction mixes in pre-plates which
are anyways 96 well pcr plates standard
and they will perform an offline reverse
transcription step in the pre-plate
after the reverse transcription
took place
the user would inactivate the reverse
transcriptase enzyme using a 10-minute
inactivation step then transfer their
reaction mix to the nanoplate and then
perform the two-step kai acuity pcr
cycling in the kai acuity instrument
now we'd like to show you guys some
application data where we quantified the
abundance of sars kovi ii using rna
extracted from german wastewater using
the methods that dominic described
previously
in the powerpoint
so here below we have nine distinct
biological samples which were taken from
the same pool of collected wastewater
and were then extracted using
mce membrane
or the concentration of retin-tot
through amicon filtration devices or
centrifugation of wastewater to form
pellets which were then extracted
we assayed the rna using the n1 and n2
assays developed for
sars cov2 by the cdc we use five
microliters
of
rna in
40 microliter 26k nanoplate reactions
and the original eluent was derived from
50 milliliters of wastewater
as you can see consistent with what
dominic saw the pellet and amicon retin
tot samples quantified sars cov2 better
than the mce membrane
we'd also like to show you guys some
application data where we tried out some
troubleshooting of techniques when
dealing with wastewater samples because
they can be tricky at times
and so we played with three variables
first we increased the annealing
extension time from 30 seconds at 60
degrees to 90 seconds at 60 degrees in
our two-step pcr system
second we investigated whether using
less eluit per digital pcr reaction
improved the quantification overall
lastly
we tried adding a well-known pcr
inhibitor
magic pill psa to see if that would also
help and as you can see using the n1
assay
using less template
increasing the extension time from 30
seconds to 90 seconds and adding bsa to
the system
all helped
in increasing the detection of sars cov2
in our wastewater samples so i would
just like to recommend that if anybody's
having difficulty with their wastewater
samples try playing with those three
variables
last but not least
we've also gathered from our experience
in quantifying sars kobe 2 in wastewater
that users coming from the qpcr world to
the digital pcr world are sometimes
surprised that their quantification
expectations aren't matched when they
come to digital pcr
and we found out that many times it's
because
concentration expectations determined
with qpcr are determined using standards
which are inaccurately quantified
here we have four
single stranded rna standards
which were placed into digital pcr
reactions and expected concentration of
a thousand copies per microliter and as
you can see
all four standards came below
the expected concentration and most
importantly among the standards there
were different concentrations
indicating that
unique features to each standard um were
off each concentration for each standard
was off sometimes by a factor of three
which would be quite significant for
important quantification experiments
so here is kaijin's solution for sars
kobe 2 detection in wastewater using
extraction methods which we developed
especially for
this task and the kai acuity instrument
and the kai acuity one step viral rtpcr
kit that i just talked about
so uh thanks for your attention and i
will be taking your questions right now